Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to this mini course that is accompanied with Orph
os Labs'
structure OS indicator. Over the next hour or however long it takes me to get
you the
information that I would like you to have, I'm going to be covering a series of
different
ideas and concepts that are going to help you with your trading and with your
experience
using the structure indicator. Again, you're here because, well, structure can
be a very,
very complicated thing if you don't have the right logic in place. And so that
's exactly what this
is. But there's more than just having the structure in place. There are a
couple of other details
that I would like to share with you that, again, like I said, I'm going to very
much help you with
your trading. So there are four main things I want to share with you in this
mini course. The first
one is the directional bias. And so you can see here, there is this little icon
inside of the
indicator. And you can move this wherever you would like to. You can have it in
the top left if you
would like. You can have it top center. And you can have it top right. You can
have it anywhere on
your screen pretty much. Again, you can have the text sizes, normal, smaller,
tiny. I am honestly
someone who prefers to have it as tiny, just like minimalism, as you can quite
see, my charts are
very minimalistic. But yeah, this is what I'm going to be covering first.
Second, I'm going to cover
my number one entry model, my go to entry model. It's the entry model that I
would say that I
probably use the most. So the confirmation in the entry itself. Third, I want
to go over a very
valuable concept that is structure in validation, actually. And you can see
here, I'm this is the
trade that I am currently in. It's also the trade that many of my inner circle
kind of live trading
students are also in this exact trade. But for many people trading my system,
you wouldn't be able
to take this trade, because the reality is, is the M15 is bullish right now.
But the M15 is bullish.
But there are a couple of key things that are happening in this price leg that
has essentially
led me to take short positions. And I've already taken partials off the table.
So I partialed out
this Asia low. And I'm going to be holding some of the position down here to
the extreme swing
lows. And so I'm actually selling the market when the structure is bullish. And
there's some very
important reasons as to why I'm doing that. And I kind of wanted to share that
with you because I
think, you know, if there's if there's anything that's benefited me the most
over the past kind of
six months, it has been understanding when to and not to follow my structure
rules. So I'll be showing
you this. And finally, I want to share with you three deep trade breakdowns. So
I'll be recapping
three different trade scenarios using three of my trading models that I use.
They are all from
the same strategy, but they are different setups. So I have three trading
strategies. But within
each trading strategy, I have multiple different setup variations. And so I
want to show you three
deep trade breakdowns using the market structure tool. Yeah, I'll show you an A
plus setup as well.
As well, I'll explain in the invalidation series, I'll explain this exact trade
that I'm in right
now, or at least I'll find the bias behind it. I don't want to confuse you too
much with the
trade itself. This is a different strategy. But yeah, this is the this is the
bias that I'll be
breaking down to. And so you can see here, we have directional bias and market
structure,
two different things, which I'm going to break down to you in the first episode
.
So those are the four videos that I am going to be breaking down with you. At
any point in this
episode, if you decide the kind of the information that you'll get in is
valuable. And you want to
take the next step, which is accessing our prosperity school program inside of
which
you probably already know. But that's where we have all of the strategies, all
the backtesting,
years and years of trades executed and all the different setups and just
everything pretty much.
I will leave the link somewhere around here that you can go check that out, or
you can
get in contact with one of them to the team and kind of get information on that
.
If that's something that you would like to inquire about. But yeah, within that
, guys,
let's kind of get straight into the first episode, which is going to be the
bias indicator and
understanding the weekly and daily bias.